[Music]
[Music]
Wow Morning Glory oh good morning
Millennials good morning everyone it is
such a grand wonderful day here in New
York City because it is bring your dog
to work today well at least it is for me
I'm Theo's in the building he's not
really behaving so you'll probably get a
nice ass shot of him from time to time
but for the most part don't be expecting
to see any mean-mugging from Theo
because he's not giving you the time of
day it's bring your tags worth today
look look turn oh look at you mom no
you're just gonna have to settle for the
booty shot it's fine it's just as good
he has a nice derriere here wait is it
on a picture for you she only had the
bottom team Oh boots with the fur
literally the whole club was looking at
her she hit the floor hey let's sing you
know Shiloh Lolo Lolo Wow he's like
spread them it's layers it's quite a
scene he is he's a man he's a man
spreader he is a man spreader it's gonna
be such a great day because the world is
just it's non-stop honestly and before
the Royal Wedding like things are just
getting wild these are getting wild we
have a couple of juicy stories for you
today you know some that require more
in-depth observation therefore like
there's less quality less quantity but
more quality stories I would say okay
and I want to jump right into it because
I know Nassau we have five but some of
them are like two and three are both
about John Cena a Nikki Bella oh my god
what he said and then her response I'm
shook to the core but first we need to
close up this Megan Marco father
situation so as after our show yesterday
they're honestly so pertinent to the
situation that we forgot even to say our
trademark line after the past 5:00
yesterday after the show yesterday and
the satisfied
Megan Merkel's dad told TMZ that he was
no longer gonna be attending the Royal
Wedding therefore no longer walking her
down the aisle and he kind of explained
how he got himself into this whole mess
where he looks like a thirst monster
general staging photos of him like
trying to be like cute and Chrissy
Teigen II by looking at photos of his
daughter online you're not being good
and you said you would what he said was
that I mean I'm ignoring Theo because he
can't take away from the premium content
or that we are my son let's deliver
deliver everyone we're gonna say quick
hi and then by to feel because it's
goodbye CEO you couldn't be here for
your anti mom see for just five minutes
right for that reason you're out not
even minutes oh my lovely I might be be
say hi to everyone before we let you go
I love you I love you so much and I want
to be your entrance job which ever done
you guys looks when are we gonna have
ends day there must be and and when ants
start pulling their own weight they'll
be adding their weight I think that the
ants mattresses should combine and start
to celebrate and say where we just like
it to take digs for the day and just you
know have a day he'll be more like a
moms day because right but it's all in
the ends so okay and ants work is never
done
it's true no else's work is never done
mega Markel well I mean she thought her
work was done right well her family is
out here in these streets just ruining
everything this isn't so sad because
like okay listen this is why it said
because he said he doesn't want to
embarrass her I can't
okay so here's I think the dads
explanation to TMZ made me think
differently about the situation
basically what he said is that he has
been approached for interviews this that
and the other
and he has not done anything but he was
approached him preparing for the wedding
which included him looking at pictures
online but the way that the world is
right but the way that we interpreted is
like this guys I'm an interesting that
cafe like so people around you know to
be like you know looking at photos
trying to the wedding he's like look
the tailor let's just him preparing for
the wedding but it came off looking like
these were can Billy don't think have a
guy I don't think that he's pure anymore
but I don't think that he's months for
general I think that he those pictures
sold for one hundred and thirty thousand
dollars like after the wedding like this
will be irrelevant like honestly if I
were him I would have done even more and
done interviews yeah well no cuz
interviews like have a way of you know
baby to surpass but taking a couple of
harmless photos I don't know but they
turn out to be quite harmful no totally
I'm like oh we're having a sound issue
it's a live show it's just really sad
that like he thinks he's embarrassing
Megan Megan and like he is but like
unintentionally also apparently he
suffered a heart attack six days ago and
he won't he checked himself out of the
hospital so that he could attend the
wedding but be like because of this mess
and his his health like he decided not
to go oh my god that is so damn sad and
Megan and Harry issued a statement okay
quote it's deeply personal Megan Marco's
father Thomas Marco was said to me
Prince Harry for the first time this
week before walking her down the aisle
on Saturday but now the bride-to-be will
become royal before the two men ever
meet that's really sad Marco will no
longer be attending the Royal Wedding on
May 19th mr. Marco obviously Megan will
be there with bells on what day as first
reported by TMZ following the news that
he had participated in staged paparazzi
photos late Monday Kensington Palace
announced in a statement that Megan was
in the midst of a quote deeply personal
moment following the surprise turn of
events
this is a deeply personal moment wait so
is it deeply personal so this is shallow
or deep this is a deeply personal moment
for miss Marcal in the days before her
wedding said a spokesman she and Prince
Harry asked again for understanding and
respect to be extended to mr. Marco in
this difficult situation I just want to
let you guys know like I am filled with
understanding and respect for mr. Marco
right now like I feel for this man for
him but I just want to know what's going
on at Buckingham Palace like do you
think Harry no stepped in it
Harry's like what the hell am I getting
myself into and I just saw another
interview with her half-sister on some
janky old like satellite news
network and it's like the paparazzi
caught like some members of her family
coming into London they just look like
soda chef oh my god
he wasn't invited to the wedding though
so they're just like they're crashing
just like London oh yeah part of the
they're probably gonna like go outside
of Buckingham Palace look how low is
dictators hey I'm related to Megan
Markel
yeah me too get in line like seriously
this is becoming a little too much for
me like I don't know it's just like well
at least miss what does the Queen think
the queen is shook but I feel like the
Queen has seen it on honestly this is
nothing compared to Princess Diana and
the storms she caused like how these
Megan is falling into line like they
can't control her family members and
what they do but you know everyone like
has their baggage no but for sure but
Diana was like perfect until she wasn't
and like Megan Marco is just starting
out I'm like a really bad foot what does
this say about the future of Harry and
Markel I mean if they can get through
this they can they can get through a lot
this is deeply personal as she said and
at least mr. Merkle had like the
wherewithal to go to TMZ and not like
some jenkki satellite news web localized
right Carly yeah no I heard she scored
the interview iCarly mycology was your
birthday yesterday so Marana do tix
what's wrong you don't like icarly are
you barking in this house I think he's
in if I can interpret um I think he's
barking because we mentioned miranda
cosgrove and he can just as an emotional
support animal as an emotional support
animal he can feel her pain should we
let him come back no okay no more tags
podcast listeners I got you it's not
funs listen to a podcast where we're
talking to a dog that you can't even
hear and she wants her aunt's day you
got it tough love tough love my friends
do cries one more time I'm gonna start
crying he's won't be so happy look at
Jacob there's just two boys day out well
that's true okay now it's good for Theo
to have some one-on-one boy time since
we have a deadbeat father named Ben
honorary uncle snitches Jacob I will
have uncle's day - totally
okay so Mary and Markel whatever their
[ __ ] names are are ruining it life
what's next um I wonder who's gonna walk
her down the aisle now so I read that
the mom is now like we'll just show
progressive and kind of Jewish because
the moms also walk them down in today
and Jewish both parents oh sweet
yeah that is progressive and I'm just
I'm really starting like to feel for
Megan wait by the way what I what we
posted on the toast yesterday breaking
the Internet
Megan Markel has kissed Lachlan Monroe
aka how Cooper's aka
also like I just some wondering like how
this is all affecting George you know
cuz he's a really sensitive kid George
oh I feel like he's going to know or
Twitter I feel like he's loving it
Prince George first name Prince last I
said George
yeah for sure I feel like he's loving
the downfall bless you but it's like
does the Queen not watch Riverdale I
feel like she never would have okay okay
this marriage if she knew that the
princess to be he had kissed a black
hood totally because she's like I don't
want that sort of it's really so crazy
like Maggie and Marco I was like no oh
my god Theo never barks you guys this is
crazy
maybe he has something to say when you
sit on my lap maybe he has something to
say come on baby do you have something
to say Theo oh come on okay what do you
have to say for yourself you want
champagne he says why is he out of
breath like mother like son it runs in
the family
okay sit next to me be a good boy don't
make me regret this okay okay I didn't
you get cozy Tigs it's just crazy how
like right now in this world everyone's
talking about Megan Marco everyone's
talking about you know Riverdale the
black hood season finale tomorrow and
like there's one their paths have
crossed it's honestly it's like God
wanted this to happen so like we even
have something to talk about this week
and at the end of the day it all comes
back to the Hallmark Channel
I wouldn't necessarily that's where they
met Hallmark Channel like I feel like
let's do a homework movie like it can't
be that hard if Megan Marco back in the
day got one know what to actually you
know it's my dream and I I need to step
on it because I think they're gonna
start filming the Christmas movie soon
actually I heard I'm like yeah that
comes in a big yeah like in know I heard
they only take like two two months to
like get done so maybe they're not like
the highest production value so I don't
think it's taking them like two years to
film these boobs no but like a good six
months mechanic a good six months a I
don't know I just need to get anyone
even if I'm just like an ancillary extra
you know just I love being unsolicited
girl in the background like the shop
yeah like hey excuse me ever seen you
before okay let's
so homework let's do it let's roleplay
okay well who i am i like the alicia
witt irony the manor is a woman mine
through the middle leading lady I'm
leading you're not you're the man okay
I'm the leading lady no no you're the
man and is my store and like we're gonna
end up falling in love like you're
looking for a Christmas cake you're the
man and it's my you're the man why I
just said if you're you you're the man
and it's still your store fine
no you don't men don't eat stores in a
hallmark movie you don't have to be
working fancy offices and then they end
up hating their jobs like what America
it's the devil the leading lady and like
the comfort of behind your little
counter at the store Oh fine cuz you're
right I do have more okay buddy so I'll
be the man no no no okay fine oh my god
you're so like you'd be the woman who
owns the store and I'll be the complex
male character who's just in town
getting a gift for his grandmother okay
and it's the holidays okay so welcome to
season's greetings how may I help you hi
I'm actually I'm looking for a Christmas
gift for my grandpappy blossom no for my
nanny Rose um she's a really speed woman
do anything for knitting she loves to
knit ever since her her leg went out and
her I just her like okay I guess we
actually have some some wonderful kids
over here ooh
and honestly homework homework hasn't
hired us yet I'm shocked okay next up we
just got to get to it because it's what
everyone's talking about if you could
see all the dog hair Jhansi know you can
john cena opens up about nikki bella
break up puts rumors to rest on today
you guys this is crazy John Cena went on
The Today Show with Kathie Lee and Hoda
honestly a little blood I heard this is
just what the grapevine said cuz you
know I'm very like in the know I had
heard that he really initially wanted to
have this kind of break breakthrough
interview on the morning toast but the
girls weren't available because one of
them has a sty and he's a he's a
germaphobe I heard yeah okay during a
visit to today on Monday the wrestler
and actor got candid about what happened
what he's doing now and what he wants
for the future well it didn't make it we
did really good gird your loins yes he
did and as for the latter to put it
plainly it's the same thing he wanted
before the split to marry Bella Tamar
Nikki that like Bella's aphorism it's
like you know first it's Percy last yeah
people with like a first names like it
sounds like he wants to marry Bella
Hadid quote it's very difficult Cena
told today's Hoda and Kathie Lee Gifford
I had my heart broken out of nowhere or
for me it was out of nowhere and anyone
who's experienced that knows it comes
with a series of bad feelings but it
also came with some hard-earned clarity
frissina
quote I've looked at myself every day
and I've tried to evaluate myself every
day and the woman I love he said for
anyone out there speculating on what I'm
doing with my life now I still love
Nicole I would still love to marry
Nicole I still would love to have a
family with Nicole okay this makes
literally no sense because their biggest
argument yeah like she wanted kids
she really wanted to get married she was
like forcing him to get married like so
it seems like there's no problem why
aren't they together that last point
goes against one of the biggest rumors
out there that it was his reluctance to
start a family with Bella that led to
the break however Cena confessed that
despite that being a sticking point in
the past his use evolved quote if you
look at me five years ago I was stubborn
selfish self focused life had always
been about me and then slowly over time
this woman waltzes in and steals my
heart he explained whether I want to
realize it or not she becomes my number
one so I'm willing to go back on to all
these things that I say and a lot of
them I was hanging on to just of
stubbornness quote I won't have kids and
it took a very strong look in the mirror
for me to be like why this person is my
number one and it's something that's
very valuable to her of course we can do
this however Cena was quick to add that
he can be a quote horrible communicator
so she may not have always gotten the
message he was trying to send as for
what was really behind their separations
like so many other splits it's
complicated I need more quote there was
a set of unfortunate set of
circumstances where our relationship
ended there's been a lot of speculation
recently recently of me being seen in
the public and everyone is thinking John
Cena is enjoying the single life no I
was supposed to be married and have a
honeymoon over these past two weeks
I don't want anybody else I love Nicole
and I'm really trying to support her and
her trying to find out whatever it is
that she wanted that made her this fall
apart in the first place and in doing so
I'm just trying to live I don't have any
other hopes other than maybe they maybe
one day we can work it out honestly this
sounds a little scripted sorry because
it's like a long monologue so what could
it be well you know I'm up at the Barnes
and apparently he's you know hooking up
with some chick Becky really yeah so
maybe he loves Nikki wants marry her
wants some kids with her but also wants
Becky you know and that part Nikki
couldn't couldn't wrap her head around
but I wonder if we will see like some of
this in well we'll see the breakup like
they're being like it's so rare that
like we get answers from celebrity
couples that were like invested in and
it's annoying cuz like they made us
invested they made us invest in like
that come up inside their relationship
and then they break up and we never get
any explanation now it's like we fell in
love with them when they were together
and now we're getting some sort of like
resurgence it's like some answers some
solutions like I'm loving it and
honestly I really feel like for the
first time there's hope for these two
like they obviously need to work out
whatever they're going through maybe
it's the other woman Becky maybe not but
he loves her and she loves him and maybe
they do want the same things except for
Becky but like we all have to figure it
out but like Nikki really like I just
but also like apparently they're still
having sex right so also Nikki Bella is
quote speechless over John Cena telling
today that he wants to reconcile and
have kids with her so she responded to
they said no I just wonder if him saying
he was like stubborn and really like we
just wouldn't have kids because she
wants him is that the first time she's
heard that I like I don't know when Alan
asked a 34 year old Tony Bella's star if
she had seen the heart-wrenching
interview he gave to Cathy and Hoda she
responded oh my god no before the
interviewer were read an excerpt from
the segment that included the revelation
as a 41 year old Walker star wants to be
the father of her children Bella
responded well I'm not about this like
during the interview Bella responded Wow
well I'm speechless um yeah that's crazy
yeah she then reflected on this season
of the e reality show being one of the
best yet before she elaborated on her
broken engagement quote I didn't think
cold feet and all that type of stuff
existed but it exists I have hope and
I'm just at a point in my life where I
feel like I've kind of lost me and I
want to find me and work on me like okay
I understand but like can't you find
yourself like no honey like while you're
pregnant with John's baby great that's a
nine months of just you know that's yeah
I don't even make a whole big cardiovert
over the wedding like just go to City
Hall get married pregnant it up just
look at happily ever after like weddings
like are so like such spectacles and
like honestly if sex and City tell me
anything it's like it's the dress
it's a dress feels finally being a good
boy I don't know how to feel about this
you guys I just want to a still very
much on there I'm cheerleading
if I were and this is good news for us
for those of us in their corner you know
he's saying everything that she wants to
hear that we want to hear so please you
guys like to think he's also like
playing a part like I think he he wants
to be a family man actor pg-rated films
at worst so yeah to see Walker's teacher
are you literally stuck like a beer
bottle up his ass yes you already ruined
it for everyone so whatever you said but
there's a character who comes out I
don't want to move for more though she
was that like the first minutes I'm
spoiler I please have you spoiling the
black hood for me I didn't yes you did
no I didn't because when I was talking
about that would take up I still didn't
know who the black hood was we were just
speculating that's not true you're
happier I think it was after the episode
no we were yes I know it was after the
episode and I'm Jack Jacob of ruined the
box hunt for me and I won't ruin it for
you guys
we already did under Instagram know some
people anything we did it yesterday to
house black hood but like there's more
to it House why could Jack had dice Tony
and Sheryl are bisexual
oh well that we found out weeks ago but
you just found out yeah I know you love
that I'm all caught up on River and I
feel like such an informed citizen of
the world know and tomorrow's the season
finale and I'm just so excited to see
what writer Ross has in store for us I
know right or wrong right or us right oh
and we did decide that tomorrow night we
are watching Riverdale together we are
filming an episode of faster Dale Gordon
recording an episode of faster Dale for
our patreon so make sure that you are a
patron I meant what do we call it looks
after no no nothing we can't use it
no faster Dale's perfect what about like
faster Dale what's another word for
after like post Dale post Dale um um mr.
book another word for after need to do
afternoon in another language or no like
what's it in like poetry uh pre Dale pre
Dale okay
River River posts what about post River
yeah laughter love it okay got it
we're recording an episode of day
laughter our number one award-winning
after-show the river doc okay anyway
unofficial official Riverdale after-show
I love not saying that I know that was
like crazy times it was like difficult
for me like physically no it was the
physicality of after Dale was on another
level and I would say the reward was
great but it really wasn't
thud well except writer Ross right
except marina Ross who I would literally
you know do a whole shower on even if no
one watched yeah except I wish like the
further the beginning of the season was
like so slow like if we were doing at
Radel like post out yeah we're doing it
no no like every episode is being
jam-packed II would be less critical
that's true when maybe we're just less
critical because we're watching these
were for joy hey I I understand that
okay this next story is it is exciting
for Aziz Ansari who's returning to stand
up after sexual misconduct allegations
speaking of stand up I wanted to talk
about Michael che and Colin Jost
yeah we went to the Robin Hood galya
galya last night which is a really great
organization based in New York that's
like trying to fight poverty and they
had like a letter sitting there then
j-rod a low
Michael che Michael che Colin Jost Oprah
Oprah
Gweneth Paltrow was on the list but I
didn't see her there I didn't see her
either but no it was just like a star so
that the Manning you I owe the man all
athletes Justin Tuck Billie Jean King
luijk
anyways Michael che and Colin Jost did a
set of stand-up and I have you know what
I'm gonna I'm gonna eat my words because
they were really funny they were who
stir and it just meet like and so I take
back the mean things that I said about
them not being funny I still think they
you know work two hours a week except
that they are the head writers for the
show but they did they're kind of
they're stand-up was like they're the
head writers but none of their sketches
actually get picked up and they went
through like all of their sketches that
weren't accepted and it was so funny I
would watch that show ya know and the by
the way look I didn't even I guess every
like person who
works in comedy like does stand-up it's
like that's how they got to the weekend
so I just didn't know Michael che did
stand-up and he was so funny and what
was really cool was that I don't think
they prepared whatsoever and if they did
it came off like they did it was come to
me it was completely like improv because
it was like like two or three awkward
silences where they were coming like
they were thinking of things to say like
and it was funny because that brought
Michelle wolf who did the White House
Correspondents Dinner came on before
them with like the most rehearsed a
routine ever like she was literally
memorizing like a Bible and it was
honestly like I really did not like her
and I did not enjoy that but like it was
just so interesting to see like the
juxtaposition of different types of
Santa as a comic myself I think the
answer and which one did you relate to
more liberal and jokes like relax
you know we're awesome I take back
saying that they're not funny because
they were hilarious I couldn't stop
laughing after then you talk about how
they'll only work hard on Saturdays yeah
oh my god I was worried that like they
think her boys yeah anyway so if they do
listen I'm meeting my words I love when
I'm wrong about stuff too it's just so
refreshing and welcome because it never
happened Leeanne Locken exactly Margaery
oh my god totally man March what's her
name mark and Marjorie Joseph still says
yeah I was so wrong about her also Colin
Jost is good-looking
yep and I'm I see how him in spiritual
all right yeah I can get it too no
totally and who do you think was funnier
because like Colin Jost jokes were
funnier but Michael chase delivery yeah
no I think Michael che was funnier like
but I also see how like I thought they
were so funny but I also see how that
funniness wouldn't translate for me
until Weekend Update where they get like
one joke out of time and it's like it
feels like you're reading the back of
the popsicle stick with the punchline
they parlay it they like set it up for
you it's like fake that was like a like
the Michelle wolf thing was like wait
for people to laugh but give the punch
I'm like she's so like that's not real
yes no it was very real and it was so
refreshing to be wrong
yeah no I wasn't expecting that cuz when
I saw that they were like the comics I
was like like yeah these guys they said
that they wanted to do a sketch about
the Oscars like how so like you know how
when someone wins are like this is
Leonardo DiCaprio's 11th nomination him
first way and they like give their stats
they wanted to do that as like with
their histories like this is Leonardo
DiCaprio's six allegation first arrests
yes
it was really funny anyways so I'm just
happy Leonardo DiCaprio isn't altered
not that we know of
Oh but speaking of we could as easily
say it's doing scan oh yeah so I'm gonna
on the fence about this Aziz Ansari
thing because like I read the girl's
story yeah I read it was they've done it
very reputable source and I read it and
I was like shocked by it and then I read
the op-ed in the New York Times about
how like in defense of Aziz Ansari I
kind of agreed with it
and I'm certainly not gonna speak on
like her experience because I can't but
like I don't know I'm on the fence about
it I don't think I don't know if we
write him off just yet well I'm Jimmy
I'm sorry when usually when something
comes out about that person like
multiple like other people come out I'm
experienced and that didn't really
happen it's like oh no no I'm just on
the fence about Aziz Ansari I'm not sure
um it's like you can't say anything so
like I've been their victim blaming
Norah specially in this situation like
unless you're the person who wrote the
New York Times op-ed and you're
retweeting it like you can't say
anything but I'm happy that he's back to
work what is it where is he doing chose
so the award-winning actor and comedian
performed multiple sets in New York City
this past week Marco the first time he's
taken a seat another thing we didn't hit
with sexual misconduct allegations back
in January he appeared at the Comedy
Cellar in Manhattan sutures from
Wednesday to Sunday
according to Brooklyn vegan Oh so it's a
lot not a person I just like loved being
a comic oh you do and like cuz now so
funny cuz you used to like hey the term
but this is a thing cuz now when people
ask me what do I do I see comedian and
it's like so much easier like I went to
this fancy like thing last night after a
Robin Hood Foundation we went to UM
Stepanek Farland by the way so hot
like oh my god I was living Stefan
Farland obviously is the voice of Family
Guy and Ted and he's on the Orval but he
actually has like the most it would make
sense he has the most incredible voice
cuz he can like manipulating his voice
so much in so many ways he's like okay I
want to sound like Frank Sinatra and he
does and it's so good and he goes out
like on tour so he did a concert at the
Carlyle last night and it was [ __ ] I
mean sang and he was so damn hot like I
was sitting like right and in his crotch
like because he was honest II hate these
days I know but I don't know families
say so is it someone that like that I
would ship I don't think you would know
her really yeah okay tell him tell me um
oh yeah so I went to like this dinner
and I met my friend Kade who was like a
mutual friend of Seth's so like oh
you're out there's like fancy thing with
all these fancy people and someone was
like what do you do and I was like I'm
coming and it was such an easier because
you didn't like what I do like a podcast
you know like I'm comedian and that was
a comedian on your morning show your
community and onion serum it's just is
an umbrella term yeah for all the things
that you do six shows I'm sorry that
makes that makes a comedian that does
make a comedian cool how to make a
comedian
I'm glad that you finally came around to
the time what do you say when people ask
you oh I just had unemployed and run for
the hills girl with no problems ah no
job no one's asked me anyway I guess I
do like oh you know what I kept away to
a podcast bassist herb it's like a video
and you see your context the morning
show it's you're the content creator
people really like it you're a content
creator i makan
no I just would rather bore them with my
roundabout response so that they never
asked me yeah look at us and learn yeah
um what were you saying that Aziz Ansari
is performing at the Comedy Cellar but
we're not sure because it's coming from
someone in Brooklyn vegan it's such a
it's in page six but yeah there's
pictures of him there from Instagram
Brooklyn vegan or like it's at a web
site or is it oh yes a so it's like from
Twitter and stuff but anyways it's funny
how that never happens to me like from
girl with no job you know and I'm like
always talking about yet totally but you
weren't at the Comedy Cellar women sees
no but like I was you know I was at this
thing I was out last night like I was
like this is so glamorous I'm like this
is so something paytrik stood right up
and I was just like envisioning what the
page six thing would say like Cody Asche
I was there too you know yeah but it
didn't have well yet have you checked
the pee oh I'm on page six I don't see
your name I'll do the same tonight
should I look on the search bar I need
to get the email of like who you send
tips - I think it's right and any time I
do something cool I'm like kind of
submit a tip about me
hold on it's on the page I mean I'm on
the website also I see a story that's
recommended for me that looks really
interesting somebody's gonna click like
oh my god this is an amazing story
million dollar listing stars Steve gold
the new honey is romancing Britain
Gastineau oh wow that's crazy if she not
bangs with him anymore because she's
nowhere to be seen so last I heard from
my internal sources that they maybe it
wasn't burning yet it might be nobody
know about glam people well like how
they are fighting over hairdressers he's
not easily won the argument
Oh God shields cockeyed because her glam
isn't so good in this picture um I just
love how she's like maintain relevancy
like sort of it's every time you think
she's about to drown and die like she
just comes up for air one last night has
a nice life it's like she's in peach
successional girls
she was the og reality star through
apparently Steven her met at a fossil
party I'm assuming that's Art Basel
hosted by mutual friends Fabian wasabi
a source told page six they are
definitely dating it was love at first
sight they felt an instant connection
and then she's on the show three oh my
god I'm dying he is hot hot hot he can
get it Britt and Steve are in la-la land
it's cute and everyone is happy for them
including me sort of that's weird why
I'm well he's Irish yeah and like
everyone wants to date his not only is
he like a star on the rise he's hot as
hell and like rich on his own and he's
like dating like a seriously coolest
former reality Tinsley Mortimer vibes
except she's not nearly as pretty and
she like and she's not bouncing back um
also this gives me like Prince Harry and
Megan Marko vibes where it's like two
people that you know that you never
thought would cross paths and here they
are happily together dating so it's just
like if they get married
Kim Kardashian be it's cheap Colts
wedding well moving that they're still
friends I don't know if they're assuming
that they're friends yes I just really
really really really really want my
friend Simon to get married so that oh
you could go to so I can go to a wedding
where I think all the Kardashians will
be out like I think um that would be
epic I know Jacob just texted me a story
from page six yeah I'm like look I'm all
page six up in here Queen Elizabeth is
allegedly livid with Megan Marco's
father I'm not wrong photos he should be
shook she should be livid with the
entire Markel ancestry Queen Elizabeth
the second is quote very angry with
Megan Marco's dad for selling stage
paparazzi photos of himself days before
the Royal Wedding
we didn't read the TMZ because she might
be a little more sympathetic said a
meeting is taking place between
Kensington Palace and the communications
office Tuesday to discuss what to do
about 73 year-old Thomas Markel oh my
god they're gonna send him to like
Siberia is really sad sad quote Lord
Chamberlain who Her Majesty and the Duke
are very angry with Megan's father oh my
god this guy has really stepped in it a
source told page technically they have
been more angry if you didn't interview
they're making it seem like this is like
the worst thing in the world they will
speak to him once he arrives about the
royal protocol arrives where incoming
the Royals are worried about the father
of the bride said the source because of
those photos markle's secretly hired an
la-based paparazzo we know very sad he
was due to land in the UK this week but
announced Monday he's bowing out okay
and then it's just a recap of everything
we told you earlier today when are they
talking to him Lord Chamberlain I feel
like he's being sent to the principal's
office
let's say Thomas Marr Col like to go to
the royal wedding and he flew to LA like
who pays for the flight as a first-class
he pays you present Marquis wouldn't pay
for any maybe the daughter would pay
just like as a gesture of a good look
obviously if good Marcos aren't paying
for the wedding right like no the
country's paying for the wedding that is
so disgusting like but like they get so
much out of it no but like yeah cuz like
people travel and like a boost the
economy but like does imagine it like
your tax payer like I'm annoyed guy we
share our taxpayer dollars went to
something that we could see on TV well
actually you can see the bridges in the
roads on TV you know it like imagine if
our taxpayer dollars went to something
so fabulous
no like glamorous right like that would
be exciting as long as taxes didn't go
up even more because then I was just
choked I'm interested to see which
celebrities attend it's always really
weird like Madonna gets invited always
the Beckham was getting better she has
her own celeb friend hardly Bianca
Chopra is it really yeah she was on
watch what happens live and gave no tea
we choose a bridesmaid yeah and she her
she's like her best friend I know I
thought it was like the most popular
show in today scene everyone talks about
it like yeah that's why you just can't
listen to anything by the way when I was
in college I took a like a media class
and actually I learned a really
interesting to to stick 90% of TV shows
that are on the air like lose money and
like aren't popular but the 10% that
like are super popular and make a lot of
money so much that like it all like it
rises all
chips whatever the phrase rising tides
raise all ships that makes no sense
though because some of those ships have
already sunk but I guess when it's like
when it's so bad they can't sustain but
like if it's a decent show and like a
decent amount of people watch it they're
not making money on it but they need
programming like yeah I just was an
interesting staff maybe it's changed
since I was a young college girl okay we
have one more small story that actually
segues nicely from this is that Pretty
Little Liars spin-off is ordered at free
form which is I don't know are all the
girls back okay I think that's what
picture that Mona and and fashion videos
and Peters Sasha Pieterse say it's just
like this is so unrealistic I hope that
in this day in this series day travel in
time ten years and all the characters
play ages like that they are like
because they're all thirty if they're
still in high school as previously
announced the show's cast includes
Sophia Carson from descent I love her I
love her and I love descendants a trend
as she plays Ava a trend-setting blogger
and Cohen of course oh I heard that that
character Ava was actually like created
you know inspired by this girl Claudia
shy do you know her yeah no I heard that
she would that's in the article Ava
transcending blogger encoder inspired by
the real-life dr. Crower job Yunos added
later sydney play took creative license
Sydney Park from the walking dead as
Caitlyn okay someone named Jeremy from
Toronto General Hospital
oh and Kelly Rutherford from Gossip Girl
as Claire Hotchkiss she's everywhere
she's also in dynasty - yes yeah
literally playing with Lily van der
Woodsen she has like one talent to play
like a mean rich white lady and she
nails it every time truly the role she
was born to play and what happened with
her kids but like did you two figure
that out member oh my god I don't know
but like I think they doubles like Kim
Kardashian was on her side and like
there's nothing you can't accomplish
with Kim but she's right
I wish Kim was on my side like just in
general like I don't think she's not on
my side I could just use her like to
speak up for me every now and then yeah
everyone would leave me alone totally
also I forget
no I forgot watch dynasty eyes I'm not
watching dynasty what was on TV last
night I did not have much minute go home
and watch it just like I didn't have the
bandwidth sorry I neither
I thought the extra hours sleep was more
important so I could me I'm conscious
that you'll I mean I still feel like
[ __ ] but I would have felt worse I need
to start like not feeling like [ __ ] and
like I thought pain vitamins would help
me know okay so like yesterday like you
know on the show yesterday I was like
not alive and I'm still not alive today
but I'm doing much better and like I got
home and I'm like it's probably cuz they
put so much crap in my body so they
literally made like grilled chicken and
string beans and I made I mean ordered
from Westville chicken up stray means it
was so good I'm like I didn't even feel
better and I know like one meal is not
gonna do it then I had a girl cheese so
like whatever well that's not like
totally unhealthy because cheese is good
like bread that's nutritious that's all
I told it's not like fried processed
trans fats then I was drinking like from
5 o'clock to like 1:00 p.m. a lot I
didn't get drunk but like at the gala I
had like a tequila soda and a half and
like I have a shot yeah no not for you
and then at the concert I had a
margarita and a half not bad not bad but
that's actually pretty good for a Monday
night yeah Jessica Szohr was there what
did you know Gossip Girl she's blonde
and she's so skinny and she honestly
couldn't have been nicer but I'm like
you're just Vanessa from Brooklyn please
go back to Brooklyn it was really cute
she's on that show the orbit which is
apparently really popular it's just on
Syfy so I've never heard of that sure
it's so funny because it's on yeah I
tell him it sound a major Network I'm
gonna totally thought it was on Syfy
because it's a sci-fi show it's on Fox
okay well it's so popular and all the
cast like came out to support and like
they were all sitting at a table and
they were like laughing having the best
time I was like I want to be on that job
yeah well we should at least just watch
it and it's pretty funny so I'm sure it
is cuz sentence arson is so funny and he
was being so funny and like so he was
singing like old school like Frank
Sinatra Dean Martin like a lot of songs
I didn't know and during random moments
in the song he'd be like killing it like
he's as mostly amazing voice
he would go to the Peter Griffin voice
or let go to the Ted Boys that's so
funny I tried together but there was no
filming and like I was getting in
trouble
like some things are just you gotta see
yeah hi RL anyways I think I got a call
I think I have a delivery and so now I'm
having a pit like I picked up so but the
OB Lily mellowed out couldn't give him
props totally take it once I get a shot
he's looking good sweating through the
spine tonight you guys it's been a true
pleasure getting to hang out with you on
this fine fine fine Tuesday morning oh
wait Jackie and I tonight are going to
an extremely prestigious event that we
must like we have to take a million
pictures oh for sure so it's just always
a gamble you know you do everything that
you can to try and look pretty
okay magazine has like their summer
kickoff party which when they have in LA
is what they film for Vanderpump rules
they always film at that party so now
they're having like the New York version
where there's gonna be like a bunch of
housewives bunch of Bravo people and
Jackie Hisle and some procedures
Mornington will report backstage but oh
man I'm so can I like too obvious like
no we're never art and this is pictures
with others under control no he's really
good about he could stand to be
thirstier we're not thirsty enough for
the industry that we're in but anyways
that's why we're still not on the
network stay tuned it's been a true
pleasure reality to hang out with you on
Tuesday
what often said this fine Tuesday
morning we are the morning totes I'm
girl with no job this is Jackie O
problems we go live Monday through
Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern Time we go
live on Facebook we go live on YouTube
so make sure you're subscribed to both
of our pages give this video a thumbs up
and then we're also available later on
the podcast app if you're commuter you
much more prefer an audio based format I
totally understand I love an audio-based
me too so subscribe leave five stars
it's really important and if you look
like a friend or like a family member
who look really good used to toast in
their life please introduce us to them
because like this show is like I learned
about this in my communications class
it's called the network effect and it's
like it only works it's like it starts
with one and then they tell one and
those two tell two and those sweet tells
you know it's an exponential growth from
and it'll be really great once we take
over the world we can only do it with
your help so thank you guys so much for
tuning in we will see you bright and
early tomorrow morning